ich habe einen Tag gegessen wie
Cristiano Ronaldo 6 Mahlzeiten 3200
Kilokalorien und das alles und
bestmöglich zu performen beim trymacs
Turnier das alles seht ihr im heutigen
Video viel Spaß fangen wir mit dem
Frühstück an los geht's es ist 9:30 Uhr
ich bin bereit für mein Frühstück
wahrscheinlich steht Cristiano Ronaldo
ein bisschen früher auf kein Problem ich
habe etwas Schönes vorbereitet und zwar
Eier die ich zu Spiegeleier braten werde
wahrscheinlich nicht mit ganz so viel
wie ich sonst gerne machen würde
Fetakäse light versteht sich etwas
Vollkornbrot eine Avocado und das äh was
auch also ist jetzt nicht wenig ne aber
es wird sich wahrscheinlich ein bisschen
unterscheiden von dem was ich sonst so
mache ich würde sagen wir machen als
allererstes mal die Eier dafür gebe ich
ein paar Tröpfchen Olivenöl in die
Pfanne und ich sag wirklich nur ein paar
Tröpfchen sonst wie gesagt backe ich das
sehr gerne so richtig schön knusprig das
muss heute reichen die Ernährung von
Cristiano Ronaldo besteht aus viel
Protein viel Kohlenhydraten wenig Fett
und sie ist vor allem anders
am Tag wie die meisten von euch
wahrscheinlich sondern sechsmal das
heißt wir werden viel essen es wird
vielleicht nicht das geschmackvollste
Essen sein aber
wichtigste ich werde beim Fußballturnier
das heute noch ansteht auf jeden Fall
performen können das heutige Video ist
ein bisschen anders ist ja auch ein
kleiner Vlog quasi zum trymacs
Fußball-Event der große Kick damit bin
ich auf jeden Fall perfekt vorbereitet
im Kaffee gönne ich mir auch aber nur
schwarz heute
sehr gut zur Zeit für die Spiegeleier
mach einfach alle drei in einer Pfanne
wir müssen heute kein Schönheitspreis
gewinnen ein oder anderen Rezept dabei
fürs neue Jahr mit dem guten Vorsätzen
und so wer weiß
anderer Mensch heute abend
ich bin auf jeden Fall das Eingeben ich
glaube dass das einzige was so ein
bisschen Spaß in das Essen rein bringt
die Avocado vielleicht auch aber es
kommt natürlich keine Butter auf das
Brot oder so sondern wir nehmen das so
wie es ist
möchten wir dass wir folgt an eine
Scheibe Brot noch eine Scheibe Brot und
unser Spiegelei das ist so traurig das
ist ein geiles Frühstück also ich bin
mir sicher ich fühle mich danach topfit
wahrscheinlich besser als wenn ich mir
irgendwie Pancakes oder irgendwas rein
Farbe gebe ich jetzt einfach so groß und
drüber genauso noch ein bisschen leid
Väter sieht doch gar nicht so verkehrt
aus ich zeig's euch mal hier ist unser
Frühstück Kaffee schwarz Vollkornbrot
drei Spiegeleier Avocado Hüttenkäse
fertig der Kaffee ist wahrscheinlich
neben Wasser das einzige was ich heute
trinken werde den direkt mal so einen
geilen besten hier mit dem Eigelb sind
Schwarzbrot Stückchen Avocado kommt
reiner
wirklich weg will ich nichts Besonderes
natürlich auch weil jeder kann sich beim
vorstellen wie das schmeckt aber ganz
verkehrt macht vielleicht schon fast ein
bisschen schwer wird so auf gesunde Art
und Weise die 3.200 Kalorien zu decken
die sich Cristiano Ronaldo jeden Tag
zuführt kennt man am besten ist bisschen
Sport was wir heute machen bei Event ist
natürlich kein Vergleich macht also auch
wenn ich meinen Kaffee für mich jetzt
schon fresh ich habe das Gefühl dass
heute ein guter Tag für wir uns gleich
wieder welche Mittagessen vorbereitet
bzw das zweite Frühstück weiter geht's
mit unserem Mittagessen ich kann so viel
sagen es ist das erste Mal in meinem
Leben dass ich mir prep mache nämlich
eine doppelte Portion die eine esse ich
jetzt die andere später im Laufe des
Tages ein Event wir haben folgende
Kandidaten hier am Start vollkommen
Tennis Zucchini und Hähnchenschnitzel
auch hier wieder keine Joghurtsoße
Tomatensoße Öl funktional ist das
Stichwort
und Brokkoli nein danke ja ganz ehrlich
sieht selten so aus wenn ich für mich
koche ihr seht schon hier drüben haben
wir Hähnchen
120 Grad ist es fertig ist Nudeln rein
und ich gehe jetzt ganz schnell duschen
[Musik]
seht okay rechtzeitig fertig Nudeln
haben 11 Minuten gekocht und wir
schütten sie ab einer Hand
wow dann sehen wir auch mal nach dem
Rechten kann noch ein bisschen Öl in die
Pfanne und das sehen unsere Nudeln gebe
ich schon mal in eine Form ist auch
nicht krank viele Nudeln eine Tasse
Nudeln pro Portion die andere Hälfte
gebe ich einfach schon mal auf Hähnchen
anbraten
nicht so leicht wenn man alt mit einer
Hand filmt viel Glück ist gleich Eric
wieder am Start wenn ein bisschen unter
die Arme greifen mit dem Film und sich
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen kenne auch
daran belustigen dass ich die ganze Zeit
so super gesundes Essen was und er kann
sich irgendwas werden mein Mittagessen
ich glaube viele Spitzensportler Essen
so oder so ähnlich wie mir meine Gabe
bzw Löffel mit allem keine Freude glaube
ich Probleme
geht echt klar also wie gesagt das wäre
schwergängiger frisch gekocht Brokkoli
Zucchini haben ein bisschen Flüssigkeit
verloren
wirklich machen wichtig ist es auf jeden
Fall gut zu würzen gut zu salzen mit dem
Paprikapulver zu arbeiten weil sonst
schmeckt wirklich noch wenig klar man
wünscht sich schon irgendwie so eine
Joghurt Soße Tomatensoße was auch immer
aber Experiment bin ich mehr als bereit
das durchzuziehen für mich fit für mich
fresh Eric nicht gleich ab hier drüben
liegen schon ein paar Sachen für den
Laufe des Tages bereit ich bin hungrig
ich habe krass aber auf spielen
so wir sind im Auto auf dem Weg zur
längstes eric hat mich abgeholt und der
war so nett mir einen Kaffee
mitzubringen allerdings sind Cappuccino
mit Milch ne ich habe so vergessen
was du heute Topper Leben bist
deswegen
ich bin aufgeregt weil ich check das
noch gar nicht ich war so einen Film mit
dem Video aber ich spiele gleich einfach
sofort richtig viele Leute Fußball
Stadium dicker das ist mein größter
Traum und du erlebst sie Leute eines
Tages wirst sehen auch erleben
[Musik]
die heiligen Katakomben Team Fritz hier
das mein Team ja wo steht jetzt CR7 ja
komisch falscher Name okay ich würde
sagen wir suchen mal das Team ich werden
alle kämpfen dann geht's auch irgendwann
bald los geht's eigentlich irgendwas
spielen zu dürfen
so katalysieren du musst cooler sein
sage ich ehrlich die Nummer drei junge
Junge
scheiße aus hier guck mal wie scheiße
das aussieht guck mal da kann ich kocht
sogar besser ist mein Trash habe ich
vorbei und jetzt sieht er noch ah ich
dachte du hast mir eigentlich ich habe
richtig gesagt
auf ein gutes und faires Match 14:45 Uhr
Zeit für den nächsten Snack und während
seine Freunde ein Drink einnehmen sitzt
Cristiano Ronaldo zu Hause geht früh
schlafen meine Freunde sich da drüben
Hemberger Bacon Pancakes Mac and cheese
wirklich unglaublich leckere Dinge
reinschaufeln sich hier in der Kabine
und ich habe mir was mitgebracht eine
Banane ein Apfel und ein Proteinshake
also ich würde wirklich lieber gerne die
Sachen essen die Jungs da drüben gerade
essen aber ich sag mal so viel wenn den
gleich hier schwer der Burger im Magen
liegt werde ich frisch wie eine Gazelle
über den Platz Rennen ich mache ja nicht
mal Banane ne ich ziehe heute richtig
durch ne ich habe extra so eine junge
Banane gekauft dass sie nicht so ganz
geht ich erwarte viel von Dir heute auf
dem Platz ich auch dass das Problem
nachdem Snack hier heißt es
ganz kurz vor drei Stunden drei
Mahlzeiten drin ich bin vorbereitet
[Musik]
so Leute die ersten zwei Spiele sind
vorbei es ist wirklich intensiv also vor
so einem großen Publikum der Aufregung
und so im ersten Spiel haben wir
unentschieden gespielt im zweiten Spiel
ebenfalls unentschieden gespielt
dementsprechend noch nicht die Leistung
die wir bringen wollten aber auch wenn
ich vielleicht nicht gespielt habe wie
Cristiano Ronaldo noch weiter essen wie
er hier meine Vorbereitung ihr habt ja
vorhin gesehen wie es gekauft habe ich
könnte mir schönere Dinge vorstellen
irgendwie dass diese Nudeln mit Gemüse
und ein bisschen Hähnchen das gut ist du
hast zwar keine Soße aber du hast jetzt
so Kondenswasser wieso
unterscheide
trotzdem einen guten Appetit ich glaube
die ich habe kann man nicht durch den
Tag gesund essen wieder wegmachen ohne
das Essen wird mir wahrscheinlich noch
schlechter gehen sagen wir so deshalb
weiter so ohne Spaß kein einziges mal
irgendwie so zu einem nicht oder so
gegriffen einfach nur Wasser durch
[Applaus]
Max muss jetzt gewinnen damit sie
weiterkommen also Unentschieden reicht
jetzt nicht mehr 20 auf max sein Team
[Musik]
immer so dazu wenig gefehlt immer das
dran war und ich hätte jedem haben
können so dumm
also Leute was soll ich sagen ich bin
wieder umgezogen
nice nur weil ich mich umgezogen habe
wir haben 21:30 Uhr
schlafen geht eine Mahlzeit brauche ich
jetzt noch Lachs angebraten mit Salat
ohne alles bisschen Dressing vielleicht
ihr könnt euch jetzt überlegen ob ich
das esse oder ob ich zu aftershop Party
gehe aber das war's auf jeden Fall von
einem Tag als Cristiano Ronaldo hat
nicht viel geholfen aber Spaß gemacht
hat danke schön gleich dabei sein durfte
bis zum nächsten Video hier ist noch ein
für dich vorgeschlagenes Video darunter
kannst den Kanal abonnieren bis zum
nächsten Mal ciao